j'avais vu leurs réaction beaucoup
d'émotions beaucoup de respect
une standing ovation pendant plusieurs
minutes je crois que ça montre bien et
c'était important de le savoir que le
soutien des Français à l'Ukraine et
massivement
obtenu de sur tous les bancs du Sénat
c'est une anime la proposition de
résolution que nous devons examiner ou
condamner l'agression russe mardi
prochain je pense sera voté à la très
grande majorité j'espère même à
l'unanimité j'avais peur sans doute chez
des épalles seuls que l'hiver voit c'est
roder un petit peu le soutien de
l'opinion publique à l'Ukraine il n'en
est rien au contraire plus les images
d'atrocité de crimes de guerre de crime
contre l'humanité ce sont publiés à la
Télévision et plus l'opinion condamne
cette agression je pense que l'accueil
qui a été fait montre bien l'accueil qui
a été fait de la radar ukrainienne
montre bien le soutien du Sénat et à
travers lui le soutien de l'ensemble des
Français est-ce que la France doit
fournir des avions de chasse à l'armée
ukrainienne c'est ce qu'a demandé le
président de la radar l'aide des avions
français je pense que il faut que la
France l'Europe les États-Unis
l'ensemble des alliés fournissent à
l'Ukraine le maximum
de ce dont on a besoin je l'ai déjà dit
je lui ai dit très clairement lorsqu'il
s'agissait des chats je comprends bien
le problème qu'il peut y avoir
concernant les avions et notamment les
problèmes de débordement sur des
territoires voisins par conséquenté
d'une question difficile pour ma part et
à titre personnel j'y suis favorable
vous êtes favorable en quelques mots
pour conclure l'adhésion de l'Ukraine
rapide à l'Union européenne et à l'OTAN
vous êtes favorable je pense qu'ils ont
par rapport à tous ceux qui ont adhéré à
l'Europe depuis un certain nombre
d'années l'Ukraine a une différence
c'est qu'elle l'a payé le prix du sang
c'est qu'elle a montré par la mort de
ses soldats par la mort de l'ensemble de
beaucoup de membre de sa population
[Musique]